okay this actually seems like a fake
headline but unfortunately it's real
Donald Trump has unleashed a brutal
attack on complicated airplanes after
the horrible tragedy involving a Boeing
737 max airplane flown by Ethiopian
Airlines over the weekend in a moment
I'll show you Donald Trump's statement
about this but I want to first sort of
set it up for you yesterday I
interviewed psychiatrist John Gartner
who has been sounding the alarm from a
mental health perspective on Donald
Trump's behavior for close to a year at
this point if not longer and what doctor
Gartner believes is that Donald Trump's
behavior is indicative of some
combination of cognitive decline
mental illness a pre dementia state or
some again combination thereof and we
talked about a bunch of examples
yesterday we talked about Tim Apple we
talked about Jerusalem and God bless the
United States of America we talked about
Trump walking away at a bill signing
without signing the bill there's so many
other examples of this and just within
hours of this interview with dr. John
Gartner yesterday we have a new example
right in our faces Donald Trump took to
Twitter yesterday and went on a
broad-based attack against modern
aviation technology and complexity
arguing that we need to go backwards in
aviation tech which of course makes no
sense as aviation is safer today than it
has absolutely ever been according to
the numbers doesn't matter to Trump
let's take a look at what he tweeted
yesterday starting with airplanes are
becoming far too complex to fly pilots
are no longer needed but rather computer
scientists from MIT I see it all the
time in many products always seeking to
go one unnecessary step further when
often old and simpler is far better
split-second decisions are needed and
the complexity creates danger all of
this for great cost yet very little gain
I don't know about you but I don't want
Albert Einstein to be my pilot I want
great flying professionals that are
allowed to easily and quickly take
control
a plane this is absolutely outrageous
the world is laughing at us because our
president understands nothing and is
proactively damaging he's doing harm by
virtue of the statements that he makes
so let's see if we can break this down
piece by piece and you tell me Pat if
I'm missing any important element of
this first of all aviation has never
been safer okay the older simpler planes
Trump is talking about crashed more
often automated flight controls of
different kinds date back to the early
20th century now what Trump may be
referring to although I don't even know
why I'm being so charitable here maybe
some elements of what are called
fly-by-wire systems where flight
controls are not physically manipulating
elements of the airplane that control
flight but are doing so through
effectively a computer through
electronic means of different kinds and
of course anytime you introduce some
kind of technology there's a risk that
that that technology will fail but
accounting for all of the redundancies
and systems that are in place to
safeguard against that aviation is safer
than ever if we want to tie Trump to
this on one side or the other you could
make the case that his shut down a few
months ago slowed down repairs and
updates to planes by hampering the
agencies that are involved in aviation
safety so on the one hand he's
completely wrong that there's a concern
about aviation becoming more dangerous
on the other hand if it's not gotten
safer at the fastest possible rate we
could point to Trump's shutdown as at
least one possible reason here and then
of course there's also just the
incredible hypocrisy pad of the fact
that there's no more complicated plane
than Air Force One which is a Boeing 747
which he flies weekly if not multiple
times per week which in addition to all
of the normal complexity of that plane
has all sorts of additional systems
including one that allows for midair
refueling in case of some emergency
where Trump needs to stay in the air for
who knows how long communication system
medical systems etc this is just dumb on
every loved
I do really don't think it's even worth
playing point/counterpoint with this one
I think it's just Trump's ego getting
the best of him he views himself as an
authority figure on almost everything
like there are those clips of him saying
that no one knows more about taxes than
me no one knows more about campaign
finance than me apparently the same
thing is true for aviation he just he
doesn't know what he doesn't know and he
has the resources to reach out to people
who actually do know about this stuff
like he could contact the head of the
FAA if he wanted to but he'd rather not
he'd rather just tweet based on his
impulses on these things yeah well this
is weaponized ignorant once again and
that's right I mean the biggest problem
isn't that Trump doesn't know anything
about a lot of the things he talks about
that is a problem don't get me wrong but
that's not necessarily the biggest
problem the problem is he's the
president he believes he's an expert on
everything and therefore he doesn't
listen to actual experts and as far as
the Boeing 737 max I mean there's an
issue with the Boeing 737 max okay it
needs to be sorted out many tragic
deaths as a result there's no denying
that whatsoever two crashes within a
five-month period of the same a version
of the 737 max happening shortly after
takeoff with sort of erratic elevation
change altitudes chances so there's an
issue here and it needs to be sorted out
but Trump's commentary is coming from a
place of total ignorance maybe he thinks
if it's too complicated for him to
understand that no one could understand
it that that's another interpretation
but what you end up with is tweets like
this and it's bad for the aviation
industry it's bad for the tourism
industry it's bad just for people who
have anxiety about flying which is a lot
of people and it's embarrassing on an
international level so there's clearly
something very very wrong with this man
whether it's what dr. John Gartner
pointed out yesterday personality
disorder delusions of grandeur or some
combination thereof maybe we will
someday be able to better sort out but
this is extraordinarily erratic behavior
make sure you're following the david
pakman show on instagram at david pakman
show the rejected voicemail segments
that we have piloted on our Instagram
page people
loving it I'm getting tweets and emails
about it what we do is we get like a
hundred voicemails a day or some maybe
even more if you consider both both
phone numbers that we have and the the
fact that on weekends they also continue
accruing we only play a handful of
voicemails on the broadcast show each
week but we have taken some what we are
calling rejected voicemails that are
just wacky or unusual in some way shape
or form and we're publishing them
subtitled to our Instagram page at david
pakman show so check that out by
following at david pakman show on
instagram while you're there follow me
as well david pakman on instagram we
will take a break and next I'm going to
speak to Hannah gurmann who's a
professor at New York University we're
going to get into whistleblowing and
leaking what is the difference between
the two
how have different administrations
handled whistleblowers and leakers why
is this so important to a free
independent and strong press all of
those questions and more we will deal
with with Hannah gurmann right after
this short break